[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نبداها بالعناوين
المنطاد الصيني يختفي من مواقع التتبع
عالميه وبكين تعلن انها لن تقبل بالتكهنات
الامريكي
نسب تشغيل عاليه في فنادق مكه 250 الف
غرفه فندقيه وتاشيره المرور تتيح لحاملها
اداء العمره
الانتهاء من سبع حدائق في شرق السعوديه
مسطحات خضراء ومرافق ترفيهيه لكل الفئات
في الرابعه ايضا
الرابعه تتجول في مزارع البابايا في غرب
السعوديه
محافظه لثموطن جديد لهذه الزراعه
والهلال يبدا مشوار العالميه الثالثه
يلتقي الوداد في كاس العالم للانديه في
المغرب
بعد اكثر من 24 ساعه اختفى المنطاد الصين
من موقع التتبع العالمي لايف رادار 24 وفي
اخر التصريحات حول الازمه اكدت وزاره
الخارجيه الصينيه ان الجانبين الصيني
والامريكي توصل الى كيفيه التعامل مع
الموقف غير المتوقع بطريقه هادئه ومهنيه
وشدد مدير مكتب لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه
للحزب الحاكم وانجي خلال محادثات هاتفيه
مع وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتن بلينكن
على انما تحتاجه بكين و واشنطن هو
الاستمرار في التركيز والتواصل في الوقت
المناسب وتجنب سوء التقدير واداره
الخلافات متعهدا لان الصين بصفتها دوله
مسؤوله ستلتزم بدقه بالقانون الدولي ولن
تقبل اي تضخيم او تكهنات لا اساس لها من
الصحه
وكان البنت اعلن ان منطاد تجسس صيني ثاني
يحلق فوق امريكا اللاتيلين بعد يوم من رصد
منطاد اول كان يحلق في اجواء الولايات
المتحده وقال المتحدث باسم البنتاجون في
بيانه انه على علم بتقارير تفيد بوجود
منطاد تجسس صيني اخر يحلق فوق امريكا
اللاتينيه دون ان يحدد موقعه بدقه
في ظهوره المفاجئ الرقابه لون صيني الاوسط
العسكريه والسياسيه في واشنطن وزاد من
توتر العلاقات المتارجحه اصلا بين
الولايات المتحده والصين
اعلن عن متابعه طائرات عسكريه للبالون اما
البيت الابيض فاعلن تاجيل زياره وزير
الخارجيه انطوني بلينكن للصين المقررات
بعد ايام
هو الرد العسكري الامريكي او في هذه
الحاله عدم الرد سمعنا تقارير تتحدث ان
الرئيس بصفته القائد الاعلى للقوات
المسلحه طلب اسقاط البلو والبنتاجو رفض
البالون الصيني هو بالون اختبار لاداره
بايدن قررت تريث قبل اسقاطه مع التاكيد
على قابليته على المناوره وشدد على ان
العمل مستمر مع القياده المركزيه الشماليه
للدفاع الجوي لكشف المزيد عن المنطاد من
دون الاشاره الى طبيعته وكيفيه دخوله
الاجواء الامريكيه
هذا البالون ذو طبيعه تجسسيه الاقمار
الصناعيه تاخذ صورا ادق ولكن البالون
يستكشف المكان بدقه اعلى فهو يرصد الحراره
ونوع الهواء المحيط بالهدف لجمع المعلومات
حوله
البالون كانت له عصداء سياسيه ايضا حيث
سارع الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب للمطالبه
باسقاطه وكذلك كان راي المشرعين
الامريكيين في الكونجرس الذين اعتبروا ان
استخدام الصين لمنقاد المراقبه انتهاك
واضح لسياده الولايات المتحده وسلامه
اراضيها وذهبوا الى مطالبه وزير الخارجيه
بالغاء رحلته الصين اسفت لدخول بالون مختص
بالابحاث والطقس المجال الجوي الامريكي من
دون قصد خاصه وان هذه الحادثه تاتي في وقت
حساس بالنسبه للعلاقات المتوتره بين
القوتين الدوليتين وبالنسبه للاداره
الامريكيه التي تحاول تطويق النفوذ
الصينيه المتوسع في عده مجالات تقنيا
عسكريا واقتصاديا سليمان العربيه واشنطن
نشاهد معكم ولان هذه الصوره او الصوره
الاقرب للمنطاد الصيني في سماء الولايات
المتحده
الامريكيه المنطاد الذي اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه رصده
وكذلك كانت ايضا من قبل صور اخرى متداوله
عبر مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي اعلنا يعني
وجوده فوق السماء مونتانا المنطقه التي
تحوي بعض المواقع العسكريه الحساسه
الصين قللت من اهميه الغاء زياره وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه بعد ان تسبب بالون
صيني ضخم يشتهب يشتبه في قيامه بمراقبه
مواقع عسكريه امريكيه بزياده التوتر
الدبلوماسي بين البلدين الخارجيه الصينيه
قالت في بيانها لم تعلن اصلا ان الولايات
المتحده والصين عن اي زياره وقيام
الولايات المتحده باي اعلام او اعلان من
هذا القبيل هو شيء يخصها ونحن نحترم ذلك
كان من المقرر ان يزور بلينكن غدا الاحد
لاجراء محادثات تهدف الى الحد من التوترات
بين الولايات المتحده والصين
من واشنطن ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه حسين
الطب اهلا حسين
الان حسب المعلومات المتداوله انا المنطقه
الصيني اختفى من موقع التتبع العالمي لايف
رايدر 24 وكانت وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه
قالت بان الجانبين الصيني والامريكي توصل
الى التفاهم حول كيفيه التعامل مع الموقف
غير المتوقع هذا الاختفاء هل له علاقه
بمصير هذا المنطاد الان واختفائه كما يقول
الموقع
صباح الخير يا خالد في الواقع منذ البارحه
رفض تحديد موقع هذا البالون بدقه واكتفى
بالقول بانه قابل او قادر على المناوره
وقد تحرك شرقا من ولايه موريتانيا اضافه
الى انه غير مساره ولكنه لم يعطي بالضبط
الموقع بدقه لذلك
يشير اليها موقع 24 في الحقيقه لا نستطيع
ان نتاكد انه دقيق لان المعلومات التي حول
هذا البلوريه بحوزه
بالدرجه الاولى بطبيعه الحال ربما ايضا
بحوزه وكاله الاستخبارات الامريكيه لهذا
السبب لا نعرف اذا كان بالفعل رادار
24 كان يشير الى البالون نفسه الذي يتم
الحديث عنه او الى بنون اخر لانه عندما
شاهدت البارحه المسار الذي تحدث عنه هذا
الموقع كان يشير الى خروج هذا المنطاد من
ولايه اوكلاهوما نحو ولايه الاباما
وباتجاه ايضا جورجيا ولكن
ترقلته بعض وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه
البارحه هو مشاهده هذا المنطاد فوق
فاذا لا نستطيع ان نجزم بان ما يشير الى
موقع رادار 24 هو المكان الدقيق لهذا
المنطاد الصيني
طب الان ماذا عن موقف الولايات المتحده او
الموقف الداخلي ايضا حسين يعني هناك
استغلال ربما كما يرى الكثير من المتابعين
للجمهوريين لهذه الازمه في صراعهم مع
الديمقراطيين في هذا التوقيت فبالتالي كيف
يمكن النظر الى التفاعلاتها في الفتره
الحاليه ومدى تاثيرها مستقبلا على الحاله
او على الاستحقاقات السياسيه الموجوده في
الولايات المتحده
خالد هذا المنطاد اثار الغموض جوا واثار
البلبله السياسيه على الارض البارحه كان
هناك هجوم واستغلال من قبل الجمهوريين
لمهاجمه الرئيس بادر ولمهاجمه ايضا
انتقادات لاذعه وجهها الجمهوريون الى
عضو المجلس الشيوخ الجمهوري جورج حولي
طلب بفتح تحقيق بما وصفه الرد المحير
والاستجابه المحيره للرئيس بايدن
وللفانتاغون لهذا المنطاد لكيفيه اختراقه
للاجواء الامريكيه ايضا هناك من يدعو طبعا
الى تجديد
سياسهم يرون بانه يسترضيها بانه يحاول كل
ما بوسعه
راضيه او انه ايضا يستخدم سياسه لينه كما
يصفونها مع الصين
الجمهوريون البارحه استغلوا هذا الموقف
ايضا وربطوا دخول هذا
تعانيها الحدود الجنوبيه في الولايات
المتحده من عبور مهاجرين غير شرعيين
وقالوا ان اعلى الولايات المتحده الان ان
تركز على امنها القوميه اذا هناك استغلال
بكل ما للكلمه من المعنى لما حدث البارحه
هناك حالات لمن يتابع ما يغرد بها
الجمهوريون في مجلس النواب ومجلس الشيوخ
هناك حاله من التهكم حتى على يقولوا كيف
تستطيع الولايات المتحده بكل ما تملكه من
معدات عسكريه وتقنيات عسكريه متقدمه الا
تسقط هذا المنطاد
طبعا الجذر يبدو انه سيستمر حتى يتم
السيطره على هذا المنطاد لانه هناك دعوات
لانزاله وعدم تفجيره في الاجواء لانزله
لمعرفه ماذا صور
الصينيون ان كانت معلومات حساسه خاصه اذا
معلمنا انه مره فوق مناطق تضم منشات نوويه
مثل مونتانا لهذا السبب هناك تخوف من انه
استطاع ان يصور
اكد انه لم يصور هكذا مناطق وقال انه لا
يشكل تهديدا عسكريا ولا يشكل تهديدا
للمدنيين على الارض كيف يتم النظر ايضا في
امريكا الى مساله الغاء وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي زيارته الى بكيم يعني الان والى
اي مدى يمكن ان تكون هذه الحادثه يعني
ربما توتر الاجواء تسبب ازمه دبلوماسيه
اكثر تصاعدا خلال فتره القادمه بين
البلدين
خالد وزير الخارجيه البارحه قال انه اجل
الزياره ولم يلغيها كما اكد على انه يامل
بان تبقى نواه التواصل بين الولايات
المتحده والصين مفتوحه
واضاف ايضا بانه سيزور الصين لكن في الوقت
لاحق هو اعتبر ان دخول المنطاد الصيني الى
الاجواء الامريكيه عمل غير مسؤول ويقود
اهداف الرحله التي كان سيجريها الى الصين
ولكن على ما يبدو ان الاداره الامريكيه ما
زالت حريصه على ان تبقي هذه القنوات
القنوات الدبلوماسيه مع الصين مفتوحه
تحاول هي والصين
لملمه الموقف وللنونه الموضوع وكان واضحا
ايضا ما ذكرته وسائل النمله الامريكيه وما
اشارته اليه وتوقفت عنده كثيرا بان الصين
ايضا كان مستغربا كيف انها سارعت للتاسف
عن دخول هذا المنطاد واعترفت بذلك بسرعه
وهذا كان موقفا اشارت اليه وسلام
الامريكيه في دلاله على ان الصين ايضا لا
تريد تصعيد الموقف مع الولايات المتحده
ان يكون هناك حرب بارده ربما بين هاتين
الدولتين العظمتين والكبيرتين اقتصاديا
وعسكريا شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
الولايات المتحده تفكر في وضع شركات صينيه
في لائحه العقوبات بسبب دعمها النظام
الايراني في قمعه للمظاهرات حيث زادت
صادره بكين من الكاميرات الامنيه الى
ايران باكثر باكثر من الضعف في عام
2022 وذلك حسب بيانات الجمارك الصينيه في
ظل الاعتماد المتزايد ايضا من السلطات
الايرانيه على التكنولوجيا لقمع
الاحتجاجات وحسب مصادر مطلعه تركز السلطات
الامريكيه على شركه
تكنولوجي ويشاركه لتصنيع معدات الرقابه
الامنيه ومقر ومدينه في شرق الصين التي
تبيع منتجاتها الى وحدات من الحرس الثوري
الايراني
تركيا من الصادرات التي يمكن ان تعزز
المجهود الحربيه الروسيه واشاره رؤيه ان
امريكا وبحسب مسئولينا تدرس معاقبه
الشركات والبنوك التركيه التي تنتهك
العقوبات على روسيا في الوقت الذي تحدثت
فيه الخزانه الامريكيه عن زياده ملحوظه
على الصادرات التركيه الى روسيا
رابع مستمره فيها بعد قليل استعدادات
مستمره للحديث او للحدث التقني الضخم
يومان تفصلنا عن مؤتمر ليبا 2023 في
الرياض
هنا العراق
وهذه الاراده
وصلنا الى اخر نقطه حدوديه بين العراق
وايران حصريا ولاول مره من مخابئ وكهوف
الاحزاب الايرانيه المعارضه فيديوهات تنشر
لاول مره عن استهدافها في المسيرات
الايرانيه
شهادات صادمه عن قمع قوات الامن الايرانيه
للتظاهرات تلفني عنك
اشلحه
ومعلومات خطيره يكشف عنها المطلوب الاول
للنظام الايراني اشخاص في ساحه السياسيه
عندهم اتصالات ومع التنظيماتنا في داخل
البلد ايران
النقشه العربيه
هي اسلوب حياه للملايين
[موسيقى]
بشغفها وحماستها بسرعه وجرعتها
من اهم دوريات كره القدم العربيه
والعالميه الى اخر اخبار المنافسات
الرياضيه حول العالم
[موسيقى]
تقاريره من ميادين اللعب ومتابعه وتحليل
لكل اخبار رياضه
وعشه اخبار الرياضه في هذه الاوقات على
شاشه العربيه
اهلا بكم من جديد في السعوديه كشفت اللجنه
الوطنيه للحج والعمره والزياره للعربيه عن
ارتفاع مؤشرات الايواء والفنادق في مكه
المكرمه خلال الفتره الحاليه بسبب توافد
اعداد كبيره من المعتمرين من مختلف انحاء
العالم مشيرتان الى ان النسبه تشغيل قد
تصل الى 70% نظرا للتزايد اعداد الزوار
والمعتمرين واضافت اللجنه ان هناك نحو الف
فندق واكثر من 250 الف غرفه فندقيه بمكه
بتصنيف يتوافق مع المواصفات العالميه
جاهزه لاستقبال المعتمرين لافته ايضا الى
وجود نحو 350 شركه ومؤسسه عمره تقدم
الخدمات للمعتمرين والزوار منذ وصولهم
وحتى مغادرتهم بعد اداء مناسك العمره
والزياره وكانت وزاره الخارجيه اطلقت خدمه
اصدار تاشيره المرور للزياره للقادمين جوا
الكترونيا التي بدورها تتيح العمره وزياره
المسجد النبوي الشريف
انضم الينا من مكه المكرمه رئيس تنفيذي
لمنصه زمزم لخدمات المعتمرين في مجال
النقل
والفنادق عمر سراج اكبر سيد عمر مرحبا بك
معي في نشره الرابعه
يعني الان ارتاد الارتفاع في مؤشرات
الايواء والفنادق في مكه المكرمه ما هي
اسبابه كيف تختلف
المواطن الهواء والغرف الفندقيه عما كانت
عليه سابقا اذا كان هناك من فوائد كبيره
يعني
طيب اهلا بكم وبكافه الساده المشاهدين
طبعا اليوم وزاره السياحه وضع الضوابط
جديده فيما يخص لوائح الايواء بشكل عام
ادت الى تاثير مباشر على رفع جوده الخدمه
سواء كانت حول المنشاه او داخل المنشاه
وضع ضوابط عاليه في تصنيف المنشات
بالاضافه الى اللائحه التي صدرت مؤخرا
ويكون النفاذها بعد خمسين يوم سيكون لها
تاثير مباشر باذن الله تعالى على تحسين
الجوده بشكل مباشر لضيوف الرحمن باذن الله
لكن بماذا تختلف اليوم
ما المواصفات يعني التي تختلف بها اليوم
هذه الغرف واماكن الايواء عن سابقتها طبعا
في السابق كان هناك عندنا عاليتين للعمل
كان هناك في اليه اليه المساكن المخصصه
للحجاج والمعتمرين وكانت تحت اشراف لجنه
معينه والان الضوابط التي وضعت هي ضوابط
عالميه دوليه انترناشونال فيما يخص تصنيف
الفنادق وفيما يخص
يعني تقييمها من قبل اللجان المتخصصه من
وزاره السياحه مما ادى الى تحسن الجوده في
هذا المساكن
ما هي الاسباب هذا الارتفاع في هذه
المؤشرات في هذه الفتره تحديدا
طبعا المدينه المنوره طبعا تعزوا الى
العديد من الاسباب من اهمها التغيير
السياسه التاشيرات الجهود التي بذلت مؤخرا
من قبل مقام وزاره الحج والعمره مقام
وزاره السياحه كان هناك جولات مؤخرا
لمعالي وزير اهل الحج والعمره لمختلف دول
العالم كانت اخرها لدوله الجزائر طبعا هذه
كلها اسباب ادت الى رفع الوعي عن سهوله
الدخول اليوم الى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه بالاضافه الى التاشيره التي اجزت
مؤخرا من قبل الدوله فيما يخص المرور لمده
اربع ايام هذه كلها اسباب مجتمعه ادت الى
وجود تدفقات عاليه على منطقه على السعوديه
بشكل عمومي وعلى مكه والمدينه بوجه الخصوص
ما المستوى التي تقدم به 350 شركه ومؤسسه
عمره اليوم الخدمات للمعتمرين والزوار
طبعا اليوم هناك تحسن ملموس وملحوظ بشكل
يومي في الخدمات المقدمه في ظل المتابعه
الحثة الموجوده من قبل وزاره الحج والعمره
وهي تشمل جميع مراحل الخدمات ابتداء من
استقبال المعتمدين في مطاراتهم بالاضافه
الى عمليات النقل بالاضافه الى عمليات
التسكين وحتى مغادرتهم سالمين غانمين وهم
يحملون تكرار طيبه باذن الله تعالى الى
بلدانهم شكرا جزيلا لك من مكه المكرمه
الرئيس التنفيذي لمنصه زمزم لخدمات
المعتمرين في مجال النقل والفنادق عمر
سراج اكبر
اعلن التمنه المنطقه الشرقيه عن الانتهاء
من تفيد سبعه حدائق او سبع حدائق جديده
وممشى في مدينه الدمام وهي تاتي تحقيقا
لمن لمفهوم يعني سنه المدن وتقديم الخدمات
الترفيهيه للسكان والزوار عبر تحقيق افضل
المعايير لجوده الحياه عبد الرحمن العصمي
بمساحه تجاوزت 52 الف متر مربع انتهت
امانه المنطقه الشرقيه من تنفيذ سبع حدائق
جديده وممشن بمدينه الدمام وذلك في احياء
النهضه والفرسان والروضه والشعله والروابي
حيث تقدر مسطحات هذه الحدائق الخضر بنسبه
60 في المئه ثمت الحديقه بناء على هويه
بصريه فريده بحيث تخلق بيئه حضريه مناسبه
لجميع افراد المجتمع وتنتج عنها تجربه
تفاعليه بين جميع افراد المجتمع سواء
كانوا اطفال عوائل او حتى من فئه الشباب
تضموا هذه الحدائق عددا كبيرا من المرافق
الحيويه ابرزها مناطق مخصصه لالعاب القوى
بالاضافه الى ملاعب متعدده الاغراض ومسرح
مفتوح الى جانب العاب لكبار السن ومواقف
لذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه حراسه الامانه في
الجديده على مواءمه الاهداف الاستراتيجيه
للبرنامج وتعزيز النشاطات البدنيه
والرياضيه لافراد المجتمع من خلال مضامير
المشاه وزياده المسطحات الخضراء في
الحدائق لزياده نسبه المسطحات الخضراء
للفرد بالاضافه الى توفير فرص ترفيهيه
لافراد المجتمع امانه المنطقه الشرقيه
تسعى من خلال هذه الحدائق الى تحقيق مفهوم
السنه المدن وزياده نصيب الفرد من مساحه
المسطحات الخضر وتقديم الخدمات الترفيهيه
للسكان والزوار عبر تحقيق افضل المعايير
لجوده الحياه ضمن التنميه المستدامه التي
تسعى الامانه لتطبيقها ضمن مستهدفات رؤيه
2030 عبد الرحمن العصيمي من الدمام
العربيه
يومان على انطلاقه الحدث متمرر التقنيه
2023 في العاصمه السعوديه الرياض
وبالتنظيما من وزاره الاتصالات وتقنيه
المعلومات المؤتمر في نسخته الثانيه
والمقرر ان يستمر من او من السادس عفوا
الى التاسع من فبراير الجري يضم اكثر من
700 متحدث من انحاء العالم من قاده
الشركات التقنيه والذكاء الاصطناعي
والتحول الرقمي
ومناقشه عدد من الموضوعات المهمه في مجال
رياده الاعمال وافضل الممارسات لدعم
الاستثمار في المجالات التقنيه
والابتكاريه فضلا عن مشاركه اكثر من 900
شركه عارضه وخمسمائه
من الرياض ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه نواف
عزيز نواف مرحبا بك كيف تبدو الاستعدادات
لاستضافه مؤتمرنيب في نسخته الثانيه
نعم خالد استعدادات تجري على قدم وساق هنا
في مقر تنظيم مؤتمر لي بهذا المؤتمر الضخم
الذي حقق نجاح كبير في النسخه الاولى خلال
العام الماضي وحقق قيمه كبيره من الصفقات
والاستثمارات الاجماليه خلال ايام المؤتمر
في النسخه الاولى بقيمه تجاوزت الخمسه
مليارات دولار اليوم
منظمين مؤتمر ليبيا يستهدفون الوصول الى
تسعه مليارات دولار كقيمه اجماليه للصفقات
والاتفاقيات طواله ايام المؤتمر ولا اعتقد
خالد ان هذا الرقم سيكون صعبا على ليب
نظرا لاعداد الشركات التي ستتواجد بينما
اتحدث الان سنكون في جوله على جزء من
الاماكن التي
المعارض التي اصبحت جاهزه او قريبه من
الجاهزيه كما ذكرت خالد العديد من الشركات
اكثر من 900 الشركه عالميه هو اقليميه
ومحليه ستتواجد في مؤتمر ليب على مدى
اربعه ايام بحثا عن الفرص والتطوير
والشراكات نتحدث عن شركات كبرى مثل
مايكروسوفت وايضا العديد من الشركات مثل
اوراكل جوجل وايضا اريكسون وشركات سعوديه
كبرى مثل ارامكو السعوديه وايضا اس تي سي
ونيوم بمتحدثين اكثر من 700 متحدث
يتواجدون طوال ايام المؤتمر هناك امر مهم
خالد وهو التنظيم والحركه المروريه في
مؤتمر ليب تم رفع الطاقه الاستيعابيه
لمواقف السيارات من 6000 موقف في النسخه
الاولى العام الماضي الى 20 الف موقف في
هذه النسخه بالاضافه الى خطه مروريه منظمه
لاستقبال الزوار بالاضافه الى التعاون
الجامعات القريبه مثل جامعه الاميره نوره
وجامعه الامام لتخصيص مواقف بحافلات نقل
ترددي وايضا هناك تطبيقات التوصيل ستتواجد
وتعمل على نقل الركاب بشكل مجاني بالتعاون
مع
مؤتمر ليب بالاضافه الى النقل من البوابات
والتنقل في ساحات المؤتمر ومن المواقف عبر
السكوتر وعربات الجولف حقيقه هذا الحدث
منتظر وهناك ترقب عالمي لهذا المؤتمر نظرا
للقيمه الكبيره التي يتوقع ان يحققها
مؤتمر ليب الذي استطاع ان يجذب الكثير من
الشركات العالم
فواحده فقط
هذه النسخه
هناك العديد من الاتفاقيات التي ستتم هناك
مشاركه كبيره من الشركات شركه اوراكل
العالميه ستعلن عن مشروع كبير تستثمر فيه
بالسعوديه ايضا هناك العديد من الاطلاقات
التي ستتم على سبيل المثال شركه جوجل
ستعلن عن تعاون مع الهيئه الملكيه لمدينه
الرياض
لمراقبه الحركه المروريه في الرياض
والازدحام باهداف معينه تهدف الى
يعني
مكافحه يعني الازدحام المروري ومواجهه هذا
الازدحام الذي يتم في الرياض في هذه
الايام بالاضافه الى العديد من الشركات
التي ستتم وزاره الاتصالات تتواجد بشكل
كبير هنا وزاره الاستثمار ايضا ترعى
الاتفاقيات ويتوقع ان تعلن عن ملي
الريالات من الاتفاقيات بين الشركات
السعوديه والشركات العالميه المشاركه في
مؤتمر ليب شكرا لك نواف عزيز من مقر مؤتمر
ليب من الرياض
ايضا في الرابعه لكن بعد قليل
رابعه تتجول في مزارع البابايا في غرب
السعوديه محافظه موطن جديد لهذه الزراعه
المنطاد الصيني يختفي من مواقع التتبع
عالميه وبكين تعلن انها لن تقبل التكهنات
الامريكيه
نسبوا تشغيل عاليه في فنادق مكه 250 الف
غرفه فندقيه وتاشيره المرور توتيه لحاملها
اداء العمره
الانتهاء من سبع حدائق في شرق السعوديه
مسطحات خضراء ومرافق ترفيهي لكل الفئات
رابعه تتجول في مزارع البابايا في غرب
السعوديه محافظه الليث موطن جديد لهذه
الزراعه
والهلال يبدا مشوار العالميه الثالثه
يلتقي الوداد في كاس العالم للانديه في
المغرب
اهلا بكم من جديد تواصل البطوله السعوديه
الدوليه للجولف فعالياتها في مدينه الملك
عبد الله الاقتصاديه بمشاركه نخبه من المع
النجوم عالميا منهم الاستراليا المصنف
الثالث عالميا البطوله التي تاتي بتنظيم
صندوق الاستثمارات السعودي تهدف الى تنميه
رياضه الجولف وزياده اعداد المهتمين
والممارسين لها وتاكيدا ايضا على الدور
التفاعلي والاهتمام بخطط العنايه بالعنصر
البشري بما يلائمه برنامج جوده الحياه
من مدينه الملك عبد الله الاقتصاديه في
رابغ ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه سعود الخلف
حياك الله يا سعود
كيف المنافسات اليوم في بطوله الجولف
يا هلا يا خالد المنافسات قويه وانا معي
بعد مضرب الجولف شويه حادخل معهم العب من
كثر ما انت شايف الحماس عالي جدا في هذه
النسخه الخامسه قول قول تبي تعلق أنا
لاعب جولف على اساس نصدق يعني انك تبغى
تشارك لا انا انا عشان يكون عشان يكون
الجو مختلف لا عشان يكون الجو مختلف والزي
السعودي فانت تدخل كذا وترفع اسم السعوديه
ان شاء الله بشكل جيد لازم تقنص يعني ما
فيها كلام عموما يا خالد البطوله يعني مثل
ما قلنا في نسختها الخامسه ومن خلال
متابعتنا للنتائج يعني نشاهد تغير يعني
بكل ساعه مما يعطينا مؤشر بان هنالك صعوبه
في التوقعات من سيكون الفائز بالمركز
الاول والثاني والثالث هذه البطوله فيها
120 لاعب فيها لاعبين من دول عربيه تقريبا
تسعه لاعبين من السعوديه ومن مصر وتونس
والمغرب وايضا الاردن البطوله غدا ستنتهي
هي مدتها اربعه ايام فيها تفاصيل كثيره يا
خالد
جوائزها تصل خمسه مليون دولار بناخذ اكثر
تفاصيل عن هذه البطوله من الاستاذ وليد
معاذ وهو المستشار لبطوله
السعوديه يعطيكم العافيه ابو الحسن بطوله
رائعه اجواء مميزه ولكن ما الهدف الذي
تسعون الى تحقيق من هذه البطوله الدوليه
اولا شارك لكم الاستضافه سعداء بكم هنا في
ملعب طبعا الهدف الرئيسي في هذا البطوله
هو تحقيق رياده في تنظيمات الدوليه لعبه
الجولف بخلق يعني منافسات على مستوى عالمي
يشارك في افضل اللاعبين الحمد لله هذه
السنه الخامسه زي ما تفضلت لاقامه البطوله
والحمد لله في تطور سنوي في مستوى
المشاركه مستوى المنافسه تروع في الابطال
الافضل في هذه اللعبه يحضر المملكه
العربيه السعوديه للمره الخامسه اعتقد هذا
هو بدايه التميز نتمنى انه يستمر ان شاء
الله للمستقبل طيب جميل الاقبال الجماهيري
كيف يعني تشاهدونه الارقام مقارنه
بالبدايات جدا ممتازه جدا جيده لكن الطموح
اعلى بكثير من الارقام طبعا بنحاول نسوي
برامج مصاحبه للبطولات حفد الحضور من
المناطق القريبه لمدينه الملك عبد الله
الاقتصاديه محافظه رابغ محافظه جده مكه
المكرمه المدينه نبى اكثر شريحه من ابناء
وبنات الرياضه وميزاتها ويطلعوا على
الجمعه عالميين هم الافضل في العالم ايضا
هذه وجهه سياحيه الان صارت لمحبي الجولف
فجميل يصير نوع من الخلط ما بين هالضيوف
الحظ المملكه العربيه السعوديه وايضا
المواطنين لاطلاع صوره جميله للمملكه
العربيه هل انتم حاطين في بالكم مثلا
فعاليات لتحفيز الجمهور انه يحضر هذه
البطولات وايش نوعيه هذه الفعاليات جزء
اساسي يتمركز حولوا دائما هدفنا في نشر
اللعبه عبر الاتحاد السعودي للكولف
والشركه السعوديه للجولف اقامه انشطه
مصاحبه تساعد على اطلاع الناس على اللعبه
معرفه اللعبه ممارتها بشكل اول مثلك الان
معك مضرب جولد سعيد مدري ايش خالد قال بس
يعني بروح اشياء طيب مره فهذه الهدف
الرئيسه نحاول نحفز فيه الناس بحيث انه
يكون عندنا شريحه كبيره من مطلعين وتحفيز
لهم وان شاء الله ناخذهم في رحله ايضا
ابتعاد بعد كذا للدخول الاكاديميه الجولف
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه مشاركه في
مزامات محليه اقليميه عربيه دوليه ويكون
عندنا نوع من الكويت العالي ان شاء الله
لابناء وبنات البلد في هذه اللعبه
السعوديه في الفتره الاخيره وسنوات
الاخيره تبهر العالم في مجالات مختلفه
والرياضه ايضا لها دور كبير فانتم عندكم
عدد كبير من المحترفين العالميين هل يعني
هنالك اقبال من قبل هم للمشاركه في مثل
هذه البطولات ولا لا في يعني بروتوكولات
معينه حتى تصل لهم الحمد لله المملكه
العربيه السعوديه الان في قطاع الجولف
برئاسه مع الاستاذ ياسر ريان ومجلس
الاداره والاستاذ نوح نوح علي رضا الان
المملكه العربيه السعوديه صارت جزء اساسي
من الخريطه العالميه للجولف نقيم اكبر
البطولات داخل وهاجم المملكه العربيه
السعوديه واي لاعب محترف الجولف اعتقد صار
عنده طموح عالي لظلام الاسره مختلف
العالميه للتنظيمها الشركه السعوديه
للجولف فالحمد لله تجاوزنا مرحله البحث عن
النجوم الان احنا نجوم عنه
حلو بكره الختام ما بعد الختام ايش عندنا
استمراريه عندنا ان شاء الله بعد اسبوع
عندنا بطوله دولي للسيدات وهي البطوله
الاولى التي تقام تحت تعديل جديد كان في
مبادره من مجلس الاداره في شركه لخلق يعني
حاله نادره بتساوي جوائز البطوله ما بين
الرجال والنساء وهذه مبادره تؤكد دعم
المملكه العربيه السعوديه للرياضه بشكل
عالمي وفيها نوع من التوازي ما بين
الجنسين تحفيز سواء للبطولات او الابطال
العالميه للمشاركه في اعلى مستوى وهذه حفز
اكثر وكان اعتقد صداها في اعلانها عن
العام الماضي كبير لدى بطولات العالميات
وكانوا جدا يحسون بنوع من التقدير الحقيقي
والجدي والفعل على الارض من المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وممثل للرياضيات الدوليه
حتكون مره اعتقد بطوله جيده مميزه واعتقد
فيها حافزيه اعلى اعلى البطلات للتنافس
موفقين جميعا يا رب شكرا لك حفظك الله
طبعا يا خالد البطوله هذه او اللعبه هذه
انا اعتبرها لعبه الصبر لانه يبدون كابتن
وليد
في الجول سلم لي عليه اول شي يلا هات هات
شو عندك بيتوقع من حيفوز بكره والشيء
الثاني ليش
يقول لك انا ما عندي خبره في لعبه الجوف
ولكن بنسال قول قولي خالد مين حيفوز بكره
ليش تطول اصلا يعني العلم
يا خالد
دايما دايما نسال عن مثل هذه البطولات
الكبيره والعالميه يعني يهمنا كثير يعني
خالد يقول لك بما انه احنا زعماء وهلاليين
فاحنا بنسال ابو الحسن بكره مين اللي
حيفوز هذا السؤال عالميين عالميين ترى
عندنا ثلاث عالميين
وايضا ليش بتغيروا المضرب اوكي مين يفوز
بكره في البطوله حقت الجولف اقدر اجابه
السؤال ده اذا هذا كان اتوقع هذا سؤال
اخونا خالد ابدا اتمنى جميع التوفيق ان
شاء الله يا رب تكون مشاركه مميزه لكن
تغيير الملاعب الجولف يخضع لنوع الليفل
اللي انت فيه
حفره او لا فكل مضرب بالاستخدام معين في
حاله معينه فتغيير اللاعب المضرب وفقد
الحاله او في المنطقه والتحدي
فهو تغييره هذا بيتم على الوضع اللي انت
فيه طبعا في الخلف تختلف مساحات تختلف
اشكال ويختلف انت فين اذا كنت مرحله رمليه
او او حتى نوع العشب اللي تلعب عليه فهذه
الطلب في غير المضرب
الاخر وهذا الاتفاق اللي عندك على خالد
يعني لو خارج اليوم كان يمكن عرف الفرق
هذا بس ما جاء معنا اليوم خالد مشغول في
المباريات الحين الله يوفقك تحياتي خالد
انا اقول ان شاء الله انه الهلال يؤدي
الاداء اللي يخلينا كلنا سعداء لانه بيمثل
السعوديه يا زعيم والان احنا كلنا زعماء
سعوديين شكرا يا حبيبي سعود الخلف مراسل
العربيه من مدينه الملك عبد الله
الاقتصاديه في رابل
الى محافظه الليث في غرب السعوديه حيث
استطاع المزارعون المحليون زراعه اشجار
البابايا بين الجبال والاوديه الصحراويه
وحصد ثمارها المكسيك وامريكا الوسطى تعد
موطن البابايا الاصلي الا انها ازدهرت في
السعوديه سلطان السلمي
امريكا الوسطى والمناطق الاستوائيه في
المكسيك هي موطن اشجار البابايا وتعد
منطقه اوكساك المكسيكيه اكبر مصدر
للبابايا في العالم
[موسيقى]
ومن على بعد 13 الف كيلو متر نقل المزارع
سعد الله الجالي بذور اشجار البابايا الى
مزرعته الواقعه بمحافظه الليث غربي
السعوديه
على المحافظه وعلى المنطقه وعلى محافظه
الليث منطقه مكه المكرمه بحيث نجيب شيء
يجذب الانظار ويكون له مردود وفائده كثيره
الفاكهه البابايا
حنا وجدنا
التربه والجو مناسب لزراعتها في محافظتنا
فبديت في زراعتها ووجدت انه
فيه فايده عظيمه فبديت ازيد الزراعه فزرعت
الاله وصلت الى الفين فاكهه بابايا موجود
عندي في مزرعتي مزرعه الخيط
[موسيقى]
لم يكن يتوقع هذا المزارع في بدايه الامر
ان تنجح زراعه البابايا بمزرعته حتى
تطاولت الاشجار وحصدت الثمار اذ ينتجوا
سنويا
320 طنا عندما نظر على الشتله تستمر اربع
اشهر وتنتج او سته اشهر بالكثير لو طولت
سته اشهر وعاد باقي يستمر انتاجها طول
السنه وعندنا ايضا الماء غزير عندنا ايضا
شجعنا على زراعه البابايا حقيقه اصبحنا
الان
نورد للمملكه العربيه السعوديه والى خارج
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وتلقى البابايا
رواجا كبيرا لدى مرضى القلب والعظام
وحساسيه الجلد لما تحويه من عناصر
وفيتامينات مهمه تعزز من صحتهم
من محافظه الليث سلطان السلمي العربيه
ايام صعبه تمر على عائله الوليد الغريبي
المبتعث السعودي المقتول في الولايات
المتحده على يد فتاه امريكيه في مقر
اقامته خلال فتره تخرجه والد الغريبي اوضح
للعربيه ان شرطه فيلادلفيا اكدت له ان
جميع المعطيات تدل على تورط الفتاه في
مقتل ابنه ويستعد الدكتور عبد الله للسفر
الى الولايات المتحده لحضور اولى الجلسات
القضائيه لمحاكمه المتهم التي سلمت نفسها
لشرطه فيلادلفيا بعد ثلاثه ايام من
الحادثه
تنتظر جدران هذه الغرفه ساكنها منذ سنوات
لكنه لن يعود فالوليد الغريبي عاد لاسرته
بعد سنوات اغتراب بحثا عن العلم في
الولايات المتحده جثه هامده جريمه قتل
الوليد قبل انهاء اجراءات تخرجه هزت مجتمع
المبتعثين السعوديين في الولايات المتحده
لكن هنا في منزل اسرته كانت صدمتها مزلزله
[موسيقى]
والله تلقيت في جاني ايميل من شرطه
الفلادلفيا وكانت صراحه ايميل
يعني اسوا ايميل مر عليه في حياتي الحقيقه
وفحوى الايميل انه
الرجاء الاتصال على قسم
ان قسم القتل
بشان الوليد الغريبي
رجعت الاتصال على المحقق فلان والرقم وفي
ارقام
قراته
يعني ما استوعب يعني
الدكتور عبد الله الذي اصطحب الوليده مع
بقيه افراد الاسره متنقلا بين استراليا
والولايات المتحده اثناء عمله الدبلوماسي
في الملحقات السعوديه يتذكر طموح ولده
الفقيد في البحث عن عمل في السعوديه بمجرد
الانتهاء من دراسته
يبدو ان طلبه المساعده وطلع به لانه وقت
خروجها الان
وبعدين قالوا لنا الشرطه انه منزله شنطتها
في السياره وجاهزه
وفي نفس الوقت يبغى يتخلص منها ما تصدق
على نفس الطلاء الحمد لله
ابدا لو حسب خطر ما راح يطلع بس يعني
تقربها له طلع
في طريق غرفتها
جو جنب بالحمام
بدات عملياتها وضربته ودفعته في الحمام
وكملت العمليه
كانت عمليه بشعه وتاكدت انه انت وبعدين
قفلت عليه الحمى قفلت
هي راحت الغرفه بس وش اللي راح اللي صار
الاول ما ندري يعني لانه في دم هنا وهنا
هيثم شقيق الوليد لم تمنعه اعاقته السمعيه
عن فهم تفاصيل الحادثه ومواساه والده
صدمه دفعته لالغاء خطط لاستكمال دراسته
الجامعيه في الخارج اسره الوليد لن تعود
للولايات المتحده مجددا لكن والده المكلوم
ينوي التوجه لهناك لحضور محاكمه المتهمه
بقتل نجله وكله امل في حكم قضائي عادل من
الرياض نواف عزيز العربيه
في بريطانيا استانفت نقابه سائقي القطارات
تضربها بالتزامن مع اضراب جزئي لاساتذه
مدارس فيكتلندا وسائقي باصات في لندن ياتي
ذلك في وقت شهدت فيه بريطانيا في هذا
الاسبوع اضخم اضرابات لقطاعات النقل
والتعليم والخدمه المدنيه وتسببت بانقسام
الراي العام بشان المئه يوم الاولى من عمر
حكومه
في 100 يوم من الحكم لم يمر يوم من الهدوء
على حكومه ريشيسوناك اضراب هو الاضخم منذ
عقد لنقابات النقل والتعليم والخدمه
المدنيه تله اضراب شامل للسائق القطارات
في انجلترا وجزئي لسائقي الباصات في لندن
واضراب اساتذه المدارس في اسكتلندا عمليه
شد وجذب بين النقابات والحكومه
ممتده منذ اشهر هم يريدون المفاوضات عبر
الاعلام فنقول لهم ما نريد ثم ياخذون
اسابيع للعوده الينا لكننا لا نتصرف بهذه
الطريقه
عبر المئه يوم في رئاسه الحكومه قتل
خلالها على اكثر من جبهه غير الاضرابات
والنقابات فاقاله رئيس حزب المحافظين ناظم
زهاوي صفعه للحكومه
ضعفوا سوناك بحسب المعارضه هو سبب تردده
في اقاله
نائب رئيس الحكومه المتهم بالتنمر
دور المعارضه هو الضغط على الحكومه
ومساءلتها في الشارده والوارده ولكن ما هو
راي الشارع البريطاني في اداء حكومه سوناك
اعتقد انه لا يزال من المبكر الحكم لكن مع
الاخذ بالاعتبار ان لزيتراس كانت كارثه
فان اي شيء قد يكون افضل من ذلك
اعتقد انهم يحاولون فعل افضل ما يستطيعون
للبلد لكن البلد لديها مشاكل كثيره موروثه
تراكمت خلال السنوات العشر الاخيره وهناك
مشاكل كبيره ستتغلب عليها البلاد
ساعتقد ان البلد تدار من قبل الاغنياء
ولمصلحه الاغنياء
سبق هذا كله استقاله الوزير غابن ويليامسن
الى جانب الجدل الذي اثير بعد تعيين وزيره
للداخليه والتي اقيلت لخرقها القواعد
الوزاريه اذا اول مئه يوم في حكومه سوناك
كان عنوانها الصمود من لندن لما مكتب
العربيه
تسبب التافه من شبكه نتفليكس في حاله من
الدار بين مستخدمها خلال الاسابيع القليله
الماضيه بعدما اعلنت عن حمله لمشاركه
كلمات المرور
اذا كنت تمتلك حسابا على نتفليكس فمن
المرجح انك تشاركه مع شخص اخر على الاقل
لكن هذا قد يتغير قريبا
نتفليكس تخطط لتقييد مشاركتك كلمات المرور
للاشخاص الذين يعيشون في منزل واحد ولضمان
تطبيق هذا الاجراء على المستخدمين الاتصال
بنفس شبكه الواي فاي مره كل شهر هذا
الاعلان اثار غضب المشتركين حول العالم
بحجه ان معظم العائلات قد لا تتشارك نفس
المنزل
عملاق البث نتفليكس وصفت خطوتها بالضروريه
للاستمرار
فنحو 100 مليون اسره تتبادل كلمه مرور
حسابها مع افراد العائله او حتى اصدقاء
اخرين
[موسيقى]
الى
الصينيه يختفي من مواقع التتبع عالميه
تعلن انها لن تقبل التكهنات الامريكيه
نسب تشغيل عاليه في فنادق 250 الف غرفه
فندقيه وتاشيره المرور تتيح حاملها اداء
العمر
الانتهاء من سبع حدائق في شرق السعوديه
مسطحات خضراء ومرافق ترفيهيه لكل الفئات
رابعه تتجول في مزارع البابايا في غرب
السعوديه محافظه الليث موطن جديد لهذه
الزر
اعه والهلال يبدا مشوار العالميه الثالثه
يلتقي الوداد في كاس العالم للانديه في
المغرب
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]